[Applause]
special SiriusXM town-hall event were
broadcasting from the Sirius XM Music
City Theatre in downtown Nashville
overlooking Broadway a high Church of
country music the Ryman Theatre in the
background I am Ken Coleman and our
special guest is the host of the Dave
Ramsey show celebrating 25 years tonight
Dave hasn't just gone faster than you
could imagine
absolutely absolutely went really really
slow and it went really really fast it's
kind of raising kids oh I got a 30 year
old kid how did that happen yeah 20
minutes ago I was telling her not to
touch the stove you know and then BOOM
now she's got kids wow did happens fast
those days and the older you get the
faster it goes that's so true well this
is a special night for Dave our entire
team many of whom are listening in and
of course many are here in the room
tonight what we're gonna do is we're
gonna ask some questions kind of go back
through the 25 years it's hard to
believe we're trying to cover as much as
we can and then of course we have some
questions from our audience here in this
theater so Dave I think it'd be fun to
start with the story that you have told
for anybody who's listened to the show
for any amount of time they have heard
you tell the story how you and Sharon
hit rock bottom but what I want to start
with is the emotions take us back what
did it feel like the reality that you
had lost it all that you had a family
and everything that you dreamed of had
come to this screeching halt the first
emotion that comes to mind is terror we
were so scared we couldn't breathe and
we had a brand-new baby
Rachel Cruz was born that year
Rachel Ramsey she was then and of course
we had a toddler Denise our oldest and
we were 28 years old I mean we were just
kids
we'd have any idea how to do it how to
figure this thing out
all we knew was as they were taking
everything and we were getting
foreclosed on and the lights had been
cut off in the water had been cut off
and you know we've made a lot of jokes
about it but Sharon said you know she
would have left but she
never car you know so you know you never
mind leaf so you know we really I was
truly a marriage hanging on by a thread
because my self-esteem was destroyed I
was such an arrogant cocky character and
then that losing everything just pounded
me into powder and she actually probably
needed someone to be courageous in that
moment and I was not I was just scared
which made her even more scared more
terrified and so it was really ugly
chemistry at that time and I think
that's why when somebody calls on the
air to this day I can I can sometimes
not every time but most the time I can
sense what's going on and I I remember
it takes me right back there it was
30-something years ago but I'm right
there I remember that heart rate
changing when you bout try to balance
the checkbook and oh god I forgot put
the check in and I'm overdraft and the
sweat comes on the palms of your hands
and over the top of your lip over the
top of your eyes and your heart rate
starts going up and you're like oh god
what are we gonna do
and it's just week after week night
after night the collections calls coming
in and it was devastating it was a very
hard time you know there's probably some
people that are listening right now that
maybe not heard the show in its totality
and they're hearing this and they have
that same feeling right now and they're
just trying to make it through night one
two or three how did you make it through
that terror well I I would like to say I
bounced back but I really didn't I mean
I said around whined and blamed
everybody else it was somebody else's
fault I was a victim and so one of the
things that I coach people on is you
know that you wrote out is not
victimhood you wrote out as self
responsibility I'm looking in the mirror
I'm going to dude you're the problem
and so once I took that on that probably
was part of when Ealing began but also
we're Christians and so our faith had an
element to it but Christians are scared
too and Christians do stupid stuff and
we were scared and had done stupid stuff
we were on that list and so you know
there wasn't like magically you said
well my faith got me through it really
it wasn't because the faith comes and
goes minute by minute
depending on what's facing you and and
where you are right then but overall you
have this sense that you know what
scripture says God says I have a plan
for you and it's not to bring you harm
but to bring you hope and you start to
decide do I really believe that that my
Heavenly Father is crazy about me
even though I'm hitting one of his
stupid kids you know I mean really and
you know and you start to believe that
and it gives you a reason to get up and
go okay we're gonna get through this and
somehow this is going to be redeemed and
here we said 25 years later and man has
he redeemed it yeah it's so powerful as
you begin to climb out together you and
Sharron begin to sense some sort of plan
and you begin to climb out take us back
to when you start to begin to help
others you kind of go all right this
isn't just about me climbing out but I
might be able to help some other people
avoid this or climb out as I am climbing
out well I've always kind of been a
teacher it is one of my gifts even
though I was never formally a teacher
but I mean I was teaching Sunday School
at the church I'm always talking to
somebody about something I was trying to
share something I mean I loved
persuading people to win you know and so
in that sense so I mean I remember a
couple around the corner that was at our
church and they found out that you know
we had gone through all this stuff and
they're like okay how did y'all get
through it because we're about to kill
each other - we're gonna get a divorce
if we don't do something and we're so
scared we can't see so they came over at
the house i sat at the kitchen table and
you know we got out a yellow pad and I
helped him do a budget and it turns out
being the real estate business I knew
their landlord and there were three
months behind on the rent I called him
from sitting in my kitchen table and
worked out a deal for them to work out
their back rent with them and we got
them in balance gave him a plan and that
was the first counseling session I ever
did and I named the idea was gonna turn
into it I ended up doing it over the
church after that for pastor call to
said hey uh know anything about
foreclosures but I know you used to buy
them and then you were one so can you
help these people and so
I went and sat down with some people and
help them stop their foreclosure at the
church and all the sudden a ministry was
born and so it started just as a
volunteer thing and it very organically
grew but the thing that we start
realizing very quickly was that we
weren't the only one that was stupid
it's like everybody is when it comes to
money it's like everybody's stupid and
if you think you're not you're really
stupid because everybody has messed up
with money I've never heard that
neighbor story and I'm picturing the
legal legal pad in your kitchen on the
table do you recall how you felt after
you said good night to them and you walk
them through that you actually got on
the phone with her landlord and came up
with a plan do you remember what that
felt like was that a spark moment that
you can now it was just like you know I
can add I can do 6th grade math with the
yellow pad they were so in the fog they
couldn't add yeah and Sharon's trying to
relate to the lady and give her some
encouragement not to kill her husband
and you know and so we were just you
were just being friends right so it
wasn't like there was some kind of
Epiphany it was just you know when your
friend comes over for coffee and they're
in a mess you sit down you help your
friend that's all we did it really
wasn't anything any more formal or
spiritual awakening than that
but when I look back on it that was the
first time we ever sat down and did that
Wow so now you're helping out a church
where you just left us on that last
answer you're helping more people you're
beginning to sense some momentum that
what you're sharing is helping people
bridge the gap from that season of your
life to going hmm maybe we do a radio
show what was that well I went on a
radio station that was broke they were
in chapter 11 bankruptcy there were no
guarantees did they randomly Dave Ramsey
show starts on a bankrupt radio station
true story wwt in radio at that time was
in chapter 11 bankruptcy and a guy was
Ronnie you know they couldn't pay their
bills obviously and so I went down and I
was on this local talk show as kind of a
financial talk show it's like a bad
Saturday Night Live skit
you know bad financial hour that was
anything that's good you know and so we
went on there and this cast of
characters on this thing on this radio
station was like WKRP I mean it was
characters and so anyway I went on as a
guest on his show to talk about a real
estate thing I was in this real estate
Club
and we started talking about helping
people with money and he had gone broke
one time and I went broke one time so we
started talking about that and the phone
started ringing and we started helping
people and he goes hey come back down
and do that again and so I did and then
he quit because they didn't pay him as
$35 or whatever and I called the guy
running it and talked him into letting
me and another guy work for free and we
said if we're really bad you can cut our
pay in half and and you know we were
really bad it was country fried radio is
dead on his other brother Daryl doing
talk radio Battalion we're talking nice
feel you know I have to move up a floor
and do that it on the country station
but I mean it's that that's how it
started it but we knew the answers to
the questions and people had questions
so they didn't care how fried we were
whether we sound like we're gonna
trailer-park or not they didn't care all
they cared was there was a guy that
cared he'd been there done that
and he cared any and he could help them
and that's all they cared about and and
from day one that's all its ever really
been yeah how much did you study some of
the because these intricate questions we
hear to on Today Show you have any
answer for these things it doesn't seem
like you're ever that stumped how much
preparation did you do in those early
days or did that develop as the show
group well we had to develop a whole
show because we didn't always have
callers mm-hmm so we had to have some to
talk about so we would do like a whole
like a live event kind of a preparation
like we were giving a speech or
something and so we had a we'd pull some
of the curriculum out of Financial Peace
University or something else and have it
sitting there and what ended up
happening was two things one was the guy
that other guy that was on with me was
an investment guy and so I learned for
investment stuff from him he learned
some of the other stuff from me and then
we would get stumped on a question are
we dancer it wrong and catch all kinds
of help people would just send you hate
mail for days you know because you
answered that wrong and tax stuff in
particular I would always mess up tax
stuff so I started learning off of my
mistakes and every time I'd screw
something up I would study it and read
it and learn that piece of the financial
world weather a little bit of estate
planning or a little bit of tax or a
little bit of investment stuff or a
little bit of this or that and then of
course as we got more popular
we were challenged on some of these
ideas and the more you're challenged the
more you have to be able to build a
defense you be able to defend your idea
or it's a bad idea and so we'd study and
learn and adjust and polish and study
and learn and adjust and polish and that
that led us to be able to create the
content but to this day I one of the
things we said from day one and I still
do it it still aggravates people in
radio is if I don't know the answer the
question the answer the question is I
don't know I had one of those on the air
today in front of 13 million people and
the answer was I don't know um forgive
me I can tell you who to call but I
don't know yeah I didn't know the answer
it was a technical rollover question
with a 457 some little nuanced stuff
that I probably really shouldn't have
even been talking about but I'm not hmm
so I just had to say you don't have to
get some better advice because I'm not
the answer I always do that on tax stuff
because my income tax stuff I screw it
up all the time
I think I think just a minute ago you
really mentioned why the show has worked
that there was a guy who cared and you
gave him some practical answers as the
show began to gather momentum what do
you think the changes that were made as
the show began to evolve when did it hit
a moment where you knew wow we're really
touching a big nerve this isn't just
local radio anymore well you know we
knew that we had back-to-back calls and
that we were getting a thousand people
on an event but we had no ratings on the
radio station zero ratings like we'd
like we had no listeners at all but
nobody ever told us to say the call
letters so we were actually illegal
because you're supposed to by law say
the call letters once an hour and do
station ID and know we know but know the
thing was being run like a barnyard not
really we really didn't have it we never
said wtn we never said 99 7 so Gaylord
buys it out of bankruptcy and they did
research and they found that you know
they said do you listen to WT n no do
you listen to 97 no do you ever listen
to Dave Ramsey on the radio I never
missed a show well that's where I was on
the air so it was like this in because
so they what they figured out was there
were a whole bunch of listeners that
didn't know what they were
- in terms of the station so it wouldn't
shown up in the ratings so they thought
a station ality they call it in radio so
every time we took a call it was wtn
welcome to WGN 737 nine nine eight six
was the you know there are seven thirty
seven nine nine seven so we had that you
know the call letters in the phone
number we had everything was a call at
his callers name caller his name caller
his name to where it just make you throw
up it was so much of it but we went to a
seven in one book from zero which is
unheard of in radio and by the time it
peaked out just about eighteen twenty
four months later it was at a fourteen
we were the number one radio show in the
entire city of Nashville of any kind
music or anything and we're in country
music ville you know so but they were
there we just didn't weren't getting
credit in the ratings because we didn't
know what we were doing we were too
stupid to do radio correctly but you
were doing it right for the listeners
and that was that's all that mattered
that's right it weren't really there for
anything else were there for that so
then you decide we need to take this
thing bigger and you decide to hire a
guy who's sitting here in the audience
on the front row tonight Blake Thompson
I think this is such a great story
because again you were just filling the
need we've got a need let's take this
thing bigger what did that look like in
your mind's eye when it came to let's
expand this well I didn't know what I
was doing but I knew you could get like
satellite time and you could put your
signal on the satellite and people could
take the signal off the satellite and
other radio stations could carry the
show and it was called syndication and
other people were starting to do it a
little bit in those days rush was three
years ahead of us or four years ahead of
us Hannity was behind us he came along
later and eclipsed us dr. Lara I was
starting to get hot in those days and so
there's some shows starting to pop up
but mainly talk radio was local only in
those days there was a few people Bruce
Williams that a show out and a few
feelings like that so we had to learn
technically how to deliver the signal
giant know anything about that but I
don't have the bias at a lot of time and
and I knew we needed somebody other than
the local radio station people to help
me do learn all this stuff and do it so
I needed a I don't know what you call
them a producer so I need to produce
something you know so get something done
so we hired a guy
from a local college he had a job that
working in a copy shop copy he was
making copies not coffee he wasn't a
barista and so you know and hated his
job and so he was glad to get to do
something else he had no idea there what
he was doing but we were gonna we were
gonna figure it out and you know we just
busted in there and made every mistake
in the world but we figured it out one
how to plug something in how to unplug
something and how to get some Engineer
office but to get it working and to get
the signal up in the air and then to
talk some radio station into taking the
signal down and putting it on and we
were such a legend by then in the in the
Tennessee and in the southeast because
of these ratings we were beating rush
nobody was being rushed we were being
rushed head-to-head we were destroying
Hannity head to head in Nashville now
rushes Hannity had beat the crap out of
me for years everywhere else so shut up
Sean but you know there are their
friends both on they're good guys but I
mean that it was a story to tell for a
little guy was a David and Goliath story
and we told that story a lot that we're
winning we're winning we're winning so
it was easy to pick up southeastern
stations but we still have that twang
and so you know Boston's laughing at us
you know like ah you've got the
beginning
that kind of stuff so California's like
here right but I mean the southeast the
Texans you know the Alabama people
they're my people you know and so
hillbillies are everywhere so here it
was great and that it took off from that
that base that the southeastern
connectivity that redneck connectivity
made it work
you know we're here obviously
celebrating 25 years of the show but
you're so unique and that the show has
given birth to a thriving organization
that is now 600 plus team members I mean
we hire so many people I can't even keep
up and I want to go back to this moment
you're beginning to get momentum
throughout the southeast you're beating
big dogs give us a snapshot where you at
on financial peace the book are you
doing live events still at this moment
because you're really branching out at
this point correct well you know there
when Blake started there was probably I
don't know eight of us or something like
that Blake it's probably eight or nine
person hired and so we had a guy working
on books and we had a guy working on
live events and I got working on
Financial Peace University a gal working
on something else you know and so and
there was a couple of you know a couple
of assistants helping us do stuff but
we're basically running around the
office with our tail on fire when you
run a small business like that you're
the CEO you're the chief everything
officer and so I got to be able to lift
boxes put them on the truck I got a bill
to set up screens for the live events
and I did you do everything you do
whatever it takes and some of those
hours were horrendous in those days it
was you know 7:00 a.m. to midnight and a
lot of days because we're doing
financial piece at night teaching the
class and we're doing the show for three
hours in the afternoon trying to run the
business during the day financial piece
the book took off simultaneously I ended
up being a publisher is attract at about
that time and so we went for him
self-published 150,000 copies to Viking
penguin came in and I said you guys
don't have enough money to buy this book
and it turns out they did so we were
able to work out a deal go figure and
that was our first real published book
they hit the New York Times that year
and so that's like six years into the
radio show before that ever happens well
how would you define your role you
mentioned earlier that you see yourself
as a teacher you really are a great
teacher is that how you view yourself to
this day
the show for three hours what you think
your primary role or maybe some other
roles as well that you fill over the
airwaves I am that and to me a teacher
is someone who can sell you an idea so
I'm a Salesman I can make you believe
that if you will do this you will win
and and here's the proof and here's the
process and here's the logic and when
you do that it's called hope and
Napoleon says said great leaders are
brokers of hope and so it's hope has
become the product for our whole company
whether it's a book an event a class
radio show a connectivity with an ELP or
whatever the product is hope and so
we're always trying to use that to
connect and give someone hope you give
them hope with a spiritual connectivity
you give them hope with an emotional
connectivity you give them hope with a
story you give them hope with facts that
says you're there and you're ok and so
it's something as simple as a guy called
yesterday and he was making a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars a year and
he got fired that morning and you know
it's easy for me to say how long do you
make that I made I made one hundred
twenty thousand dollars for five years I
said okay here's the deal you've made
over six figures there's a very high
statistical likelihood if you believe
that you're gonna be okay that there's a
gravitational pull that's always gonna
pull you over six figures because you
have ridden that bike you know what it
feels like to ride that bike if you've
made 60 and you've never made over 100
it's harder because you've never done it
they always say make the second millions
easier it is just because you know what
you can be done you know I've done it
once I can do it and so you know it's
the same thing I can do it once I've
done it I can do it so all I was doing
to him was he's in the middle of his
emotional funk because he got fired and
I yet I can speak life on turn and go
okay here's the right things that you
did here's the good things you got
here's your talents here's where you
screwed up you should have been fired
when he told us why you and I are you're
on the air with me and here's why you
shoot you should have got fire a young
guy but I said you know but you've got
the ability to and all I did is speak
life onto him and go cuz that's what
people did to me when I was down I had
people kicked me when I was down but
most people give you a hand
most people say you know you're really
not as ugly as your life looks right now
you really don't suck as bad as
everything looks you're gonna be better
and when you tell people that and you
give them a reason to believe it that's
logical
you're a purveyor of hope what you talk
about your different personas that you
have on the air because sometimes you
just get after somebody but you're
always carrying but you'll just tell
them exactly how it is and then I've
heard you dial it back and and just be
compassionate when a single mom is on
the line and has faced a tragedy in her
life lost her husband and her partner
when you begin to kind of figure out I'm
this way with this call I'm this way
with this call were you comfortable
being tough when you had to be tough was
that natural for you or did you develop
that over time I'm probably a lot
tougher and blunter now than when I
started I was a lot softer mmm
sugar sweet like sweet tea soft but but
I started figuring out too that you know
and even running our organization over
the years one of the things we say
around our place when we're dealing with
each other is to be unclear as to be
unkind so you've got a team member
that's misbehaving and you don't tell
them then you just continually get more
frustrated that's not fair to them
you've been unkind to them you thought
you were being nice like southern
passive-aggressive nice but you really
weren't because you can tell them what
they were doing and so I'm not helping
someone when I go when that kid
minimized the reason he got fired on
that call I can't let that lay because
if I do it's not good for him I never
jumps and jump on somebody and thump
them for the entertainment value I say
never almost never because the only
I do it when somebody calls mad at me
and they want to disagree with me now
shoo them up like a meat grinder just
for the because it's great radio you
know but and my pulse rate doesn't
change I just eat them alive it's fun
and but but that doesn't happen once in
a blue moon these days because nobody
calls to disagree because I'm right but
but the most the time when it's the
different people like that if I'm being
99.99% I'm if I'm being tough with
somebody it's for them it's not for the
listener it's not for the entertainment
value it's for them even when I hang up
on somebody like the fourth time I tell
you to do something and you argue with
me
I'm moving on you called me up to get me
to endorse your stupidity you didn't
call me up for advice and I'm moving on
to somebody else and so it's like I
can't help you you're on hold and that's
a that's our we put you on hold and that
means you just got hung up on you just
don't know it yet but I'm not going to
argue you into winning I'm gonna show
you what winning looks like and if
you're broken and hurting I'm gonna meet
you there another soft tender way cuz
that's how people met me when I was
broken and hurting other times when I
was bowed up and I was acting like a
victim and somebody else's fault a
friend of mine would say thump and go
you know you're not gonna get better as
long as you think it's somebody else's
[ __ ] cuz this is your fault and that's
the best stuff that ever happened to me
in my life and so I want to be that that
loving uncle or dad that somebody never
had or whatever in there and you know it
upsets some of my Christian friends
because they think you're supposed to be
sugar sweet all the time and to be
unclear is to be unkind I'm not an
enabler one of the things that impresses
me so much about you is that over this
period you have been the day-to-day CEO
of an organization that has continued to
grow and you're on the air for three
hours and I know because I'm on your
team I get to see you do meetings from
the moment you step in to the moment you
walk into the studio and then many times
in meetings after three hours just
curious when you walk in on any given
day I know the phone lines are just
ready to go people are lined up because
they need help
what do you mentally do or how do you
mentally
where to go from that CEO leadership
role to that friend that teacher on the
air well after doing it for a few years
you get into a rhythm of but I used to
have a thing a Hebrew word on the screen
we used to have screens up in front of
us computer screens they're now down in
the desk because it's all cool but it
was the word Shama which means the the
real answer behind the answer and so and
I wrote below that get behind the
question because a lot of times the
question they're asking is not what's
really going on and so I'm always trying
to get behind the question what's what's
behind the question what's really going
on because sometimes you dig and you
pick a little bit and then all of a
sudden you got a marriage problem in
there but they're calling about
something else or you're you know they
really have a gambling issue and they
really are calling about something else
and so there's something else going on
so I'm digging in that and we know we've
got a little group of people that just
show up it can be a big group if they
wanted to be but only about five people
show up I was 600 and we pray before we
go on the air God take this three hours
and use it it's yours and I help me to
be effective help me to feed your lambs
and help me not say something stupid
that runs everything because you can run
an entire career in a minute and 16
seconds on the air people have done it
and as it's a powerful thing these
microphones well I'm telling you this is
a powerful event because we've got real
Dave Ramsey show fans listeners here in
the theater and we're gonna take some of
their questions leading this off is
Jason Jason what is your question for
Dave I guess my question is what is the
origin of the debt free scream ah that's
a great question I wish I had done that
on purpose it's so genius I didn't do it
on purpose it was an accident a lady
called and I don't know how many years
ago people ask me about this all the
time and it was somewhere 17 to 20 years
ago something like that I have figured
out that range it's something like that
it wasn't in the first five years but it
was a you know and you know we're
teaching people how to get out of debt
we're saying sell everything and you
know be intense take six jobs beans and
rice rice and beans don't go to a
restaurant don't go on vacation you know
dial it in baby
game on and and this woman called from
Grand Rapids I do remember that and from
the moment I picked up the phone she
machine gun me verbally I didn't have I
couldn't say work she just sold
everything a guy came to my house Davi
he I sold him the bushes out front of my
house
[Laughter]
it was so long ago we didn't have email
we had fax machines in the studio and we
you could fax in your questions so the
fact starts going off and I'm reading
them this is the best call you've ever
had they do that again and I didn't do
anything
I don't even get to hang up the phone
now I just picked it up and it was it
going you know and we just kind of like
Blake and I kind of laughed about it we
anything anything about it about two
weeks later this old country guy calls
up he's like hey Dave
yeah I want to do that you want to do
what I want to scream you want to scream
what I'll scream I'm debt free man like
that woman did I'm like what and he said
yeah I've been working my butt off man
like 16 jobs I ain't seen my wife and he
goes off and tells the whole story and I
went well alright so I mean like and I
looked at each other we went there's
something magical about this it's weird
but there is some
and so we kind of we talked about it if
we get off the air we used to do a
debrief Lara and Blake and I every week
every day every day after today when we
come off the air we go okay what went
wrong what went right what can we do
better kind of do a CSI an autopsy on
the show that day and so we were talking
about it we're going maybe people want
to celebrate you know their victory and
so I went on there and I said if you
like did all this stuff and like got out
of debt and you want to scream your debt
free
you can call in I think that and people
start calling in they start calling they
start calling in and and then we were on
FOX Business and a guy came on the
weekend to our office and mailed his
final payment and our office mailbox
took a picture like you know taking
pictures mail on his final payment from
our office mailbox and we used that debt
free scream on FOX Business and I was
asking I'm like dude were you from
Indianapolis and he drove to Nashville
I'm not you drove to Nashville to mail
your bills I mean that's just whacked I
wanted to be at your place your place is
where it all happened your place is
where I first heard I could do this and
believed I could do it your place man
and so it's like this traveling to Mecca
thing and so we're like okay and then a
guy comes in we have the bookstore
across with a coffee shop and a guy lady
comes in and she wanted to use the
bookstore phone and call and look at me
through the glass and so so she's
stretching the phone over and they kept
doing that for a couple years they kept
breaking the phones cuz they would pull
them off and they'd drop and hit the
floor you know and so we finally got
smart and put in headsets and I would
say 80% of our debt free screams now are
in the lobby people travel from all over
the world we've had them from Australia
we've had them from the UK we've had
them from Guam travel to be in our
offices to celebrate this milestone in
their life that they finally became
debt-free it's so visceral and it's the
most-watched thing we have on YouTube it
there's something about people real
people telling real stories that were
they really got to win in an area of
your pain that in
are you that that it is it's the most
popular iconic thing I've ever seen in
business or in speaking or in teaching
any out of everything we've done I mean
to the point I'm walking through the
airport the other day with a friend of
mine a guy yells he's like hey Dave I
see you in November and Dave Ramsey
never ends I said yeah hey he goes I see
you in November and my buddy's like
who's that I said I don't know and he
said well what is he coming to see you
in November for I said well that's the
tribal speak that's tribal language dude
that means he's gonna be debt-free in
November and he's coming to do his
debt-free scream he knew what he meant I
knew what he meant my buddy's like what
are they talking about but the tribe our
tribe gets this stuff at a real deep
level and so we've started understanding
story in the power of story a lot more
when my friend Donald Miller and a few
and Seth Godin and a few others on
tribes and so we started to understand
what happened there but if the initial
parts of it were accidental we were only
smart enough to realize something was
going on so we didn't squash it but we
didn't invent it we've tried to invent
some other stuff that didn't work but
nothing has worked like that yet ever
Dave I've heard you talk about that it
wasn't intentional but you figured out
that the audience is the hero in that
moment they are the ones who did all the
work you were the trusted guide that
really is what has made it so magical
and I've told my friends and talk radio
this all over America the famous big
ones and the little ones that are trying
to get going radio stations - when you
make your when you make yourself the
hero in the story and you're on the air
you are not appealing at all when you
make yourself the guide for people's
journey and they get to be the hero in
their story they're Rocky
you're just Mickey yes they're Luke
Skywalker you you are simply Yoda
be Yoda it's a lot more satisfying
you'll be a lot more successful because
people don't want to hang out with other
heroes they want to be the hero in their
life they want to be the hero in their
story they want to get out of debt they
want to become wealthy they want to be
successful in their marriage with their
kids and you know they don't want to
hear all the time about how successful I
am I don't give a rip about that except
to the extent it means I can help them
and so keep keep your keep
focus off of yourself it's a weird type
of humility but it's an accurate measure
of how why people are really there
they're really not there because they
think Dave Ramsey's all that they're
there because they want to be the hero
in their story Jason thanks for the
question up next is Matthew here in the
audience Matthew what's your question
for Dave yeah Dave my question is at
what point in the show's history did you
start saying I'm better than I deserve
and what prompted that I heard someone
say it like most of the things I say I
stole it I and I don't remember who it
was I I can think back ok so what year
you can help me with this mr. politics
what year was Bill Clinton elected 90 to
92
okay then I started we started the show
in 92 he was elected in November we
started in June so I've probably been
saying it for 25 years then the only
reason I remember that was after I had
been saying it for about a year and a
half Clinton was in office and he said
it and someone said oh you've been
listening to Dave Ramsey and he went
over there Ramsey and so he had heard it
somewhere too and used it the reason I
picked it up was for me it's a statement
of grace I am better than I deserve but
because of Jesus I am better than I
deserve and I deserve hell and I'm not
going and so it's it's a theological
Christian statement for me but it also
has become kind of one of those tribal
things we've even extended it to where
we said okay so much parking your car
are so much delivering a pizza and they
say and you ask them how they're doing
they say better than I deserve you have
to give them an extra tip because that's
code for I'm working this extra job to
get out of debt and your job is on the
other end of that's to help them you got
to get up there tip and so servers
everywhere even they don't listen to me
have learned to say
that's pretty smart I like that thank
you for the call Matthew I want to ask
you this I don't know if you can
possibly do this but I'm gonna try to
get you to give us a specific story if
you think back on all of the calls there
have been some amazingly emotional calls
real life happening right there
on the telephone with you some tragic
stuff is there a most emotional call for
you meaning you really had to fight
through it to get through it because it
really tugged at your heart
you probably remember the first ones
even though they might not be the most
if that makes any sense
I am more apt to cry on the air than I
am to completely lose control laughing I
laugh a lot but I've lost control
completely twice laughing and we had to
go to a commercial worked two times in
25 years like 13-year old girl at the
lunch table giggle laughing I can't get
it back okay but I've lost control
crying a lot more than that when someone
calls in and you just get caught up in
their story there's two that come to
mind that I just couldn't breathe the
there were old calls her a long time ago
but one was when we first invaded
Afghanistan one of our big stations is
in San Antonio Texas and a huge army
presence there obviously a huge base
there and a lady calls me on Monday and
her husband was in Special Forces an
army had been killed in Afghanistan on
Sunday and they came by and saw her
Monday morning and an hour later she's
on the phone with me on national radio
going tell me the story and I just I'm
talking to this Widow she's got two
little babies I can't even think and the
good news is is that you know one of the
things that's happened us is we've been
able to build this huge network of
coaches that we have trained in
financial financial stuff financial
coaches a network of investment advisors
our LPS and our smart Wester pros and a
network of churches 40,000 churches have
now taught Financial Peace University
now the military when they lose one of
their own they come around
the spouses beautifully they do a great
job but she called me in the middle of
the initial throes of her grief and the
responsibility of that was breathtaking
and so I spent a little time whether I
said listen just don't make any big
decisions that's what we always tell
folks when they lose a loved one don't
make any big decisions don't make any
big decisions and then I was able to
plug her in Laura picked up after that
Laura was on the phones in those days
and plug her into they had the chap on
C's they've already the military's
wonderful and but we were able to plug
her in local church got around her a
coach that got life insurance money
coming out their ears at this point so
you gonna have some investment people
and you just get a group of people
around her and let her move slow and
have wisdom and the multitude of
counselors safety so we were able to
surround her and give her this hug more
than just a two-minute radio answer to
something like that and the other one
was a guy in Atlanta called me and he
was so calm I didn't get it at first but
the story basically was he had just left
the oncologist and the oncologist had
told him he had two months to live via
cancer it was all over him they didn't
metastasized and he was on his way home
to tell his wife and he calls me how do
I get in this lineup and you find out
you're dying I'm just I'm the first guy
you call and all it was was he wanted to
walk through very saintly very calmly
logically his estate plan and make sure
okay I want to make sure I got
everything in place because that's gonna
help me emotionally grieve this and walk
through this with her knowing that she's
cared for and so we walked through just
a checklist and say okay where are you
spiritually do you know the Lord where
are you with your will where are you
with your life insurance and how to
start walking through the checklist of a
thing and he had pulled over the side of
the road he was on a cell phone and I
said a man can we just can we just pray
for you and they kind of started
breaking up then the call and he said
yeah
I got to go home now I'm gonna talk to
her I'm just like we gotta go to a break
I can't breathe you know my throat is
just completely tight and I look up and
Lara and Blake are both crying you know
it's just like y'all are no help but you
know these people there's this medium of
talk radio is so intimate and there's
something a little bit anonymous about
it because you're not on camera mm-hmm
and so that gives people permission to
go places sometimes they wouldn't go
even with one of their best friends or
even with their priest or their pastor
and because it's they got that a little
bit of an anonymous thing and they can
tell me stuff that really they shouldn't
tell me and they sure shouldn't tell me
in front of 14 million people but they
do it's amazing but I'm listening to
that and I also think that has a lot to
do with trust he trusted you enough he
had listened to you enough that in this
moment of despair he trusts you enough
to call you and ask you how serious do
you take that trust how it scares me to
death it's a tremendous responsibility
it means that if I mess up in my
personal life and it's on the front page
of the newspaper
I'm violated that and it's not like a
celebrity so I have a responsibility to
my fans it's not one of those things
like a sports guy or something like that
this is like I lose my ability to help
them if I break that trust if I violate
it
and so I'm pretty black Ferris itical
fanatical about trust stuff about who
I'm around where I'm around and people
and that kind stuff and people with
cameras and stuff and the type of
picture they want to take with me in
what situation and how that's gonna be
perceived somewhere I'm just whacked
about it cuz I can't violate that I
cannot lose that mmm all right next in
our audience with a question is mark
mark what's your question for Dave what
was the funniest story and our weirdest
call you have received over your 25
years out here how do you choose that I
was a long list of those my
oh man
huh one of them that we caught I can
remember three that I can use up and I
think I can tell them without causing a
problem one of them was this guy calls
me up that was just dumber than a rock
and he has this idea he's gonna put a
payphone in his house and his family is
gonna put the money in the payphone and
he's going to take the money out of the
payphone and so he's gonna have a free
phone and I was like dude who gave them
the money to put in the phone I did and
when you take the money out of the phone
or who's got the money I do I said do
you not know your dog chasing its tail
you have to you don't have a free phone
because with the payphone you have to
pay for the line anyway and you're just
a dog chasing its tail and you if you
don't pay for the line there's gonna be
an air gap you're not gonna have a
service so I just started laughing and I
was just like this is the dumbest thing
I have ever heard and I'm actually
answering the question so I'm as dumb as
he is and I started laughing so hard
they had to go to break early because I
couldn't I was one of the times I
completely lost it on the air but other
funny ones I got called me up right
after Janet Jackson's Super Bowl thing
we didn't we didn't run a delay before
that but they find CBS half million
dollars for that wardrobe malfunction
things so and they started really
leaning in on you know what could be
said on the air and they came by and
kind of warned us and we thought it half
million dollar fine because somebody
drops an f-bomb we don't have a we don't
have a delay we're out of business and
so we put a delay in we put a 10-second
delay in which almost all shows up we're
already running but we didn't get calls
that were weird I mean man the next week
after I put that dump the next week this
guy calls up and goes hi Dave my wife
says she won't have sex with me if I
don't make at least $650 a month what do
you think about that and I said well I
think I'd get to work
maybe the best advice you've ever given
me
he starts cussing and yelling screaming
you know good blankety blank blank blank
blank blank blank you're just like her
and you know what well no not exactly
like her but I wasn't making any offers
but uh oh my gosh but ten seconds is an
eternity you can say a whole lot of
stuff that disappears so I kind of let
him talk for me and laughed at it was a
dude none of your stuff's making the air
and really get a job you know and I'm
just hung up on him mmm that we dumped
it it never made the air but we laughed
for days about that and we used to do a
stupid tax hour was the other one people
would call in and say stupid stuff they
had done to lose money and some of them
are just bizarre but this guy calls up
and he goes yeah so I put my wife's
breast implants on a credit card and
then I catch her in bed with my boss so
I drug him out in the front yard and
beat the crap out of him and I got fired
I got arrested I got a divorce I still
had to pay the credit card bill and I
never touched them things
[Applause]
Wow yeah we had to go to break on that
one it's like a country song right there
it really was you should write that it's
some of your friends to put away you
John Rich in here let's go get out it's
a hit
all right we're gonna go next to Andrew
in the audience Andrew what is your
question for Dave yeah if you could go
back and do it all again is there
anything you would do differently oh
yeah always there's always something you
do differently yeah I I'm a I am my
hillbilly for sure and if y'all don't
know about hillbillies hillbillies don't
do drive-by shootings if you offend them
they buy the house next door and lay
siege it's a different mentality and so
when we would lose a radio station and
someone would violate a contract and in
radio business is pretty filthy business
as far as people don't know what
contracts mean until you get big enough
you can sue their pants off and so we
would just get hammered by these
companies and they would just
straight-up all I to us and I would get
so angry because when I lose a station
in Las Vegas that was the first time I
remember doing this that means all those
people don't get helped a single mom all
those people I'm talking to and so we're
like up in Vegas we had a 2,000 people a
personal event we come home radio
station people are all like that's best
event ever and the next week they cancel
the show against a confident violation
the contract and so I basically went on
the air they gave it like a two-week
notice or something I'm like you can't
give it two week notice you have a
six-month contract I'm gonna you know
and so I went on the air which I really
should not have done it was low-class
and basically told all the fans to go
over there with pitchforks and torches
to the radio station and to call they
called so many people called that they
couldn't get business done they shut
their phones down for like a week
and people were protesting out front and
so later on I tried to get a radio
station in another city and they had
heard about that and probably not the
best plan at the time it felt like the
correct thing to do we were we had been
we had been messed over and I felt like
they needed their face punched in and I
was in the process of doing it and I've
done stuff like that more times than I
wished I had and more times than my team
wished I had but there's part of you
have to fight to win - if you're just a
wish you don't win and so you got a
fighting scratching claw and I probably
just sort of had a lot of more class
about my fighting scratching and clawing
and if I was to do some of that over I'm
a little more polished today I still get
I still get with stuff if it needs to be
somebody needs if we need to get with
them I can still do that if I need to
but I handle it in a little different
way and don't create such a spectacle of
myself in the process and my wife is
going yes you should not do that so it
was such a great question I want to do a
couple follow-ups on that you kind of
shared some things you would do
differently because you didn't do them
the right way but things that you did in
the early days the hustle factor that
anybody listening in here tonight there
on that journey there in those humble
beginnings things that you're glad you
did it that way and you'd do it again
because it made you and this show and
the organization who and what they are
today yeah if you're out there growing
something the Bible says don't despise
small beginnings this started on a card
table on my living around and sitting
there with that couple that night with a
yellow pad and and then it started on a
broke radio station and the things we
did right where we were smart enough to
not be under the illusion someone was
going to do it well for us meaning we
didn't sell the show to somebody and so
a lot of the shows were growing up and
they were being sold 50 million or 40
million or 78 million or you know these
are numbers that really happened all
around me in the first 10 years of the
show once we got to about 100
50 stations we were making some pretty
serious advertising revenues so we're
very attractive to these publicly traded
companies who were scarfing up all these
shows and owned them and we're the only
nationally syndicated radio show in
America in the top 20 shows that is not
corporate owned we're certainly the only
one in the top four or five that's not
corporate owned and it's not no slam on
my friends that work for corporate
that's fine that they just employee of
that company and they do great they make
a lot of money that's fine but we would
have lost control of the ability to do
the mission that we have had we done
that and so that's something we did
right we didn't sell I remember sitting
with a one of these radio consultants
which in the radio business there's
about three people that are real
consultants and the rest of them it's
consultant just means unemployed wish I
was on the air and so they're just
twerps and so I'm sitting with this guy
when these radio conventions and he's
all arrogant and kicked back and he goes
so Ramsey what is your end game in game
goes well when are you gonna sell what's
your in game aren't you building this to
sell aren't you are you gonna take your
public what are you doing what's your
end game dad you just don't even
understand us I can't even answer that
intelligently inside of an hour our end
game is helping people and we're gonna
use the show to do that and we have to
make money to stay on the air to hire
all the people that cause us to do that
and so the money is a fuel that causes
us to be able to help people that's our
end game Raj Khanna corny and I went see
I told you you wouldn't understand but
you know corporate America doesn't that
doesn't help with you a quarterly stock
price you know so I don't you know we
just do what we do with excellence and
we do it so well
and have gotten so big they can't ignore
us and you know we're the 800-pound
gorilla now in the space and so but but
what we did right was we wouldn't have
survived we would have been put on the
shelf with somebody else and not gotten
the attention that we wanted and so
every time somebody didn't take good
care of us it gave us that much more
energy to continue to fight scratch claw
and stay independent your show is about
real people their lives and their money
and we've heard tonight it's very purse
because of that focus over 25 years as
you look back what have you learned
about people anyone can win anyone can
win a lot of people don't think they can
but that doesn't mean they can they may
not know how to they may not know the
tactical steps they may not have the
whatever but I don't care if you're
southern or northern liberal or Democrat
liberal Democrat or conservative
Republican I don't care if you're a man
or a woman I don't care if you're
Hispanic african-american white whatever
purple I don't care if you got green
hair if you look like you fell into a
tackle box I don't care it doesn't
matter you can win you can win you've
got to be willing to ask yourself the
question what has to be true that's not
true today about me in my life for me to
be able to take that next step up and
anybody can win now some people got a
lot more obstacles than others I mean I
meet people with incredible disabilities
that have overcome them and they're more
successful than supposed whole body to
hold minded people you know because they
just they had a tremendous desire an
engine inside that believed they could
win and they've done amazing things and
we've interviewed some of them on the
air over the years but you just you look
back and go but the problem is people
this is a son the very person who's got
it all you got everything you need
except belief you just don't think you
can and so our job is to make you
believe and when we can make you believe
when that light bulb comes on over the
top of your head like one of those
cartoons that's when the people at
Ramsey solutions and the Dave Ramsey
show have had a good day why do you keep
coming back to the mic every day oh I
love it
it's fun I mean who wouldn't I mean if I
wasn't mean man that won't be me are you
talking about
wonderful life I mean people actually
care what I think and I get to tell them
what I think all day long oh my gosh who
gets that you know some people go a
whole week and nobody asked them
anything about what they think you
that's true that's really interesting
pretty it's pretty ridiculous
all right two-part question and I know
you I get the privilege to know you and
I know you don't like the word legacy
but here we sit and the reality is if
you quit tomorrow
you've left an incredible legacy a
hundred years from now two-part question
how do you want the show to be
remembered and then what do you want the
lasting impact to be hmm that's a deep
question Coleman well it's 25 years I
figure I had to give you something to
think about
yeah really um how do I want the show to
be remembered I want the show to be
remembered as the show that started all
of these other shows that we're now
launching including the King Coleman
show the the Rachael Cruz YouTube
channel the Chris Hogan podcast and on
and on because that'll keep keep it
going and it's the it was this the one
that started it and he really wasn't as
good as those other guys but he's just
the one that started it and that that'd
be a pretty good legacy right there
because I'm not really as good as all
those others they're really gonna be
better than me they're way ahead of
where I was at their point in their
career they are on a trajectory you're
on a trajectory with your stuff is just
incredible I'm so proud of our team and
where it's going on that so yeah just
won't be that'd be a great legacy be the
one that started how do we want it to be
remembered or what we want be the impact
well that's a pretty spiritual answer
but it is the truth that I'm not going
to tell you anything else is it sounds
it sounds a hyper spiritual but I'm a
Christian and so if I can get somebody
that doesn't know God to get to meet God
they don't know Jesus to get to meet
Jesus I've had a great
des and so if we leave a whole bunch of
those behind that'd be a whole lot
better than just getting people out of
debt getting them out of debt would be
good but if we can leave that behind
somebody that you know they've met
somebody that wasn't weird religious you
know they were just somebody just a
regular person that just loved God and
it changed their life and so God changed
my life he changed my life mmm and for
me to get to talk about that and
somebody get to meet God because I'm
yakking about getting out of debt on the
air and then they go I never heard
anybody talk like that and they actually
want to know something about it and I
get to talk to him about it directly or
indirectly that's about as good as a
legacy as we could leave how does it
make you feel when you get results from
the team that say millions of people
have gone through Financial Peace
University and you start to think about
the millions upon millions of dollars
that people have paid off in debt
literally changing this is the phrase
you use their family tree and you sit
here tonight and we reflect on 25 years
what does that mean to you when you lay
your head down on the pillow at night I
didn't do it I just showed them how to
do it they're the hero mmm they did it
they believed that they could win and
they took the steps to go win and they
probably got the snot beat out of them
along the way we all do the rocky on the
on the ropes in the end you'll need real
you know but he won he won every single
time you want but I think but almost
don't know what everybody's just
whatever looking bad bad metaphor but uh
you know point being that it's I was
just the guide I was not the hero and so
the end of the story is not that the
Dave Ramsey show is the hero we're just
a really effective guide mm-hmm
25 or more well I've told Blake and my
Rams and kids and you've been in some of
these conversations and Laura that I'm
gonna stay on the air until I don't make
sense and y'all have to tell me when
that is
you